add a resume is someone who has been
uprooted from where they belong
say for example if a human child was
stolen from their crib and raised as a
fairy instead you would say that that
person is at de Rosnay aren't you
excited you're going to be a very and
live in the world where time stands
still
when nobody can see what you're up to
ever again it sounds quite sinister when
it's put like that doesn't it Darris neh
is an upcoming psvr adventure title by
from software and I can just imagine my
viewer retention dropping as soon as I
mentioned it's an exclusive VR game but
don't leave right away here's my take on
this game and I'm curious to see if you
agree so the videos that you love to
watch on this channel exists because of
Miyazaki's fragmentary method of story
telling the stories of Dark Souls and
blood-borne are just basically puzzles
that we put together and tell and
they're far far richer for it so
considering it's been confirmed that de
Rosnay will follow this exact same
method of storytelling when you think
about it who better than from software
to design a mystery adventure story if
you don't intend on purchasing a psvr
just to play this don't worry because
I'll be here covering the story on my
channel so you can experience the game
through me when it releases in de resume
we play as an unseen fairy exploring a
boarding-school frozen in time and when
you touch an object or a being they'll
briefly spring into motion providing
exposition or progression to help you
piece together their story sadly our
character is completely invisible to
them and quote no one will ever see what
we're up to
but Miyazaki hopes that we're going to
feel a sense of joy or happiness as we
convince the pupils here that we
actually do exist at this gameplay demo
at e3 had players searching the Academy
for a type of sleep-inducing hub and it
was in all kinds of random places but
once you found them all the character
intended to put them in a soup as a
prank which would make the students pass
out if they drank it but were quite a
mischievous character really although I
don't know if poisoning and drugging
people counts as mischief but hey
in contrast with something like
bloodborne de Rosnay is supposed to be a
somewhat endearing game from the outset
although the game is expected to have
some really heavy thought-provoking
themes as well and here's where it gets
really interesting
so Miyazaki's been saying that they
resonate draws a lot of inspiration from
this 19th century poet named Fiona
McLeod whose poems have these really
really heavy themes of sorrow and
isolation but Fiona's poetry also
heavily references supernatural Celtic
folklore and I sort of dove into that
folklore when I was researching it and
there are some really fascinating
creatures and stories in there many of
which have clearly influenced Dara Sanae
for example I learned about the S she a
supernatural race that are sort of
comparable to fairies or elves
on the surface a lot of fairy tales
paint the air she as child like
mischievous beings but there is a really
dark side to their race one that is
creepy and downright malicious they're
not just innocent fairy-like beings I'll
give two examples both of which overlap
directly with garrison a first the story
of the changeling children hundreds of
years ago it was believed that if you
didn't watch over your child or take
measures to ward off the fairies then
they might steal your baby and replace
it with one of their own this was done
for pretty malicious reasons most of the
time like using the human child as a
servant and in the trailer for darris on
a we see a child who is supposed to be
excited at the prospect of being raised
as a fairy kind of sounds like she's
been swapped so there are some parallels
with the changeling children second
there's even this black cat in the
trailer which is possibly a reference to
the cat ISIF another creature of the
she the cat Sethe was a black cat that
some believed was a witch that could
transform into a cat and back nine times
and according to some Scottish folks the
cat Sethe could steal a soul from a
corpse before burial which was why a lot
of burial rites had people making a lot
of noise and distraction at the time and
finally the most damning piece of
evidence it's a common belief that the
air she this very race reside in an
invisible world that coexists with the
world of humans just like the world of
de Rosnay where we are an invisible
being that can interact with humans and
their world so the game will apparently
consist of eight chapters each about the
children at the boarding school and I
know that so many people in the comments
are going to be saying that this is
nothing like from software but from
software actually does have a long
history of really quirky titles just
like this one not the least of which was
a game called eco night which was this
mystery adventure game in the exact same
genre as de rasa name and Miyazaki says
as much he says that they're using this
as an opportunity to revisit their past
while also learning about VR and taking
a chance and experimenting on it with a
smaller scale project basically it's not
what a lot of us were hoping for but it
definitely sounds like this is gonna be
healthy for the studio's creativity and
like I said before if they can apply
their storytelling methods to this genre
and have it work I think that's really
good for them as a studio because their
storytelling methods are Bar None the
best in the industry in my opinion but
for now we'll just have to wait and see
what de Rosnay has in store speaking of
stores I also wanted to remind you guys
that humble monthly has just refreshed
and you should check it out it's
basically this bundle that gives you a
bunch of really really well priced good
games this month features two games that
I really liked for just 12 bucks there's
a hat in time which is this fantastic
platformer that's on par with Mario
Odyssey in many ways and also conan acts
which looks like it's a ton of fun to
play with friends for $12 you get these
games instantly plus a ton of other
games at the end of the month
this video isn't even directly sponsored
by them I just wanted to let you know
the link in the description does support
me and it also supports charity too if
you're interested but I'll see you in
the next video which is prepared to cry